i have a concept especially about
keyboard players who sing
because we don't have our hands to
express ourselves
so i think that's why a lot of keyboard
players ray had a different rock
you know stevie has a different rock you
know even me i have a different rock
and i think it's because this is the
only thing we have that can
express what we're feeling that in our
faces hey what's up gq i'm pj morton
and this is the breakdown
[Music]
first up so
what do we play
there's definitely been live situations
where uh i just had to
fall in and figure out what this song
that i never heard was
more often than not where i grew up in
church
my dad being the pastor would pull out
songs
or old hymns that he grew up on that i
never
heard in my life and i would just have
to try to follow along and figure it out
part of the beauty i think of being
creative
is not being fearful of the unknown it
usually takes you to a place
shout out to john bates my fellow new
orleans brother
fellow purple knight same high school so
they actually
recorded his hands to get the authentic
playing for the movie so
he is a genius he's a virtuoso
and so i knew that the plan couldn't be
anything but amazing in the
in this movie
[Music]
when you're improvising usually there's
an unspoken
language going on for you to know when
it's your time to take a solo
and sometimes it is actually verbal like
in this clip the bandleader she told him
when it was his turn
uh sorry i zoned out a little back there
being in the zone is uh is is
unexplainable
um i know everybody watching that scene
could relate to
losing yourself is pure bliss it's like
i always feel blessed and like that i
just have an extra cheat code that
everybody doesn't have because when i'm
going through stuff
or feeling sad or something or i lost
somebody that i love or
i can go and play and go to another
place
every emotion i wanted to say every word
i wanted to say was speaking for me
next up big piano lessons
three years
i think this song for a lot of people is
is the first song they ever learn
uh even if they before they know they're
gonna be a musician in life
uh just as a kid this is this is one of
the first
[Music]
uh bass notes and trouble notes so i
would say that bass is the foundation
is that um and treble
is up higher so in this regard
you have
[Music]
and that's the treble but then you got
the bass to hold it down
kind of tells the whole story this is
all by itself
that's light and you don't know what's
happening but this makes it feel like a
full
song it completes the story
next up rey i signed you because i
sensed something special in you
not because you sound like nat cole or
charles brown
first of all it's the opposite of where
we are in music today where
they were looking for him to be
absolutely original they didn't want him
to be nat king cole they didn't want him
to be
anybody else they wanted him to be ray
charles i think this is
profound because a lot of times today if
something's a hit
or popular then they do the opposite
they say i need one just like that let
me go get that
sing it yeah it ain't like i could read
the lyrics okay
well it's uh key of g okay
so that's funny if we're talking about
keys uh he said the key of g and i
pressed the g and
they're not even in the key of g so it's
giving away some of the truth already
here we go two three you can talk about
the pit
barbecue the band was jumping the people
too they're doing the mess around
one other thing that's cool i don't want
to keep making it about music today in
the music industry but like
his head of his label wrote his hit
single
how many heads of music and labels
executives could write a hit
single right now in music today but it
shows
how much care was put into the music uh
back then
[Music]
stride piano is basically
where it's striding it's usually going
back and forth and walking
on its own you see this left hand
walking so like
[Music]
if rey is you know maybe one of the
first
if not the first to really bring mixing
that soul
and that gospel in that church they
called it devil music when he
changed the lyrics and made it r b songs
but his that was his style
i have a concept especially about
keyboard players who sing
because we don't have our hands to
express ourselves
so i think that's why a lot of keyboard
players ray had a different rock
you know stevie has a different rock you
know even me i have a different rock
and i think it's because this is the
only thing we have that can
express what we're feeling that in our
faces
[Music]
i always end in some type of flurry at
the end of songs when he did that i
smiled because i mean that
that is probably something similar to
what i would have done
you just put the cherry on on top at the
end you know
next up love and mercy
[Music]
i may not always love you
but long as there are stars
above you i think his playing was
just okay uh but i think
it's because if the the playing wasn't
the focus necessarily
he was writing the song sometimes i'm
playing
to show that i can play or for
the keys to be a feature and sometimes
it's just passive i think in this way it
was just a tool
in his toolbox to get his idea out the
acting was great because that is the way
you would be playing not perfectly
when you're trying to figure something
out
[Music]
i wouldn't call this simple i would call
it like sneaky simple like it gives the
appearance that it is simple
which is the genius in it like that that
that's what makes this one
the best songs of all time it is not
simple by any means
it's changing keys all the time it's
like moving
constantly i can't just sit down i can't
just play it right now
because it's doing so many changes but
the melody stays
simple on top of all those changes which
is what makes this song so brilliant
i think brian wilson is one of the
greats god only knows is
one of my favorite songs of all time i
mean like i think
top three best songs of all time but i
think his playing
um much like a lot of my favorites
uh who are singer songwriters their
playing
is only theirs and its signature to them
i love singing songwriters who are
perfect for their songs
and that's how i think of of of brian
wilson's playing
next up rocket man
[Music]
yes songs can get written like that i
mean i've written some of my greatest
songs in
10 minutes you know and some that
weren't as good
took you know a month
you just never know because i've written
horrible songs in 10 minutes as well
but that's the that's the exciting thing
about creativity
is you never quite know how it's gonna
come at you you never
quite quite know when you should take a
long time on it or
or just let it be
recording your piano part and singing at
the same time
uh some engineers won't want you to do
it because it if
the sound of it it makes it harder to
separate things but i've recorded many
songs that way
because playing it and singing it at the
same time
puts you in a different place than if
the piano is already there and then
you're singing your vocal on top of it
of course it can happen but i know when
i'm playing i make different decisions
vocally than i would if i'm if i wasn't
playing
next up the pianist
that looked like live i mean it looked
like he was actually playing that in the
moment
and it was it was brilliant it's not
something that you can just pick up that
takes years and years of
of studying and practice i definitely
think that classical has had an
influence i think as creators
we will pull from many things so if we
hear something
we may not take the whole piece we may
not take the
that of it but we'll take something else
from it
it's difficult playing in nicole a a
specific memory came to my mind
which was a special night i was playing
the white house president
obama's first year but it
was also the coldest my fingers
had ever been in my life when your hands
are locked up
it's hard to play any notes let alone
something like
quickly because you can't even feel
where the keys are
that is not easy i want you to know
we're
that that that's hard to do right there
that's like stride on another level the
way he's doing that
his playing was pretty perfect i mean he
was pretty on top of it
there is something that i noticed
towards the end that could be viewed as
a mistake
like a a note slip or something but it's
almost like
it would have been too perfect if that
didn't happen it it kind of gave
humanity to it
i am the the like number one
supporter of perfection in in mistakes
that perfection comes from a combination
of
unperfect things coming together next up
call me by your name
that sounds different did you change it
well i changed it a little bit
why i just played it the way list would
have played it if he'd
altered box version as creators we
think of other people's styles and use
their styles to change another song all
the time and my sister was
a classical musician we would take those
classical pieces all the time
and like church them up you know or or
add some soul to them
oddly enough you know like one of my
biggest songs
is is a remake of the bg's how deep is
your love
but it's really just the same thing i've
been doing
with my sister since i was a little kid
which is how would this person do it or
how would this
solve you know how can this be a soulful
version of this
and and i couldn't have made that out of
thin air i couldn't have
written how deep is your love out of
thin air but them being brilliant
allowed me to
add my thing to the conversation
yeah his facial expression i feel like
he he had some anger built up
inside it looked a lot like rebellion
and i think
the best musicians and the best artists
are the ones
where it all comes through you next up
soul food
[Music]
i mean it's kind of like you know genres
gets crossed so much i guess i would say
this
it's kind of classical in its nature but
it felt like a pop ballad at first
and then they went into
and that is more like a r b type
gospel thing so they they went through
the different genres
and then when the beat came in it it
went from like classic pop
to to r b
[Music]
i would adjust my playing to to a
dancer's movements
you know sometimes there are musicians
who are there to do
what they're there to do and it doesn't
matter what else is happening
to me the worst kind of that's the worst
kind of musicians the ones that are
aware
not just of a dancer but of the drummer
and how loud or soft he's playing or the
bass player the guitar player
being aware makes you a better musician
so
being able to adjust and give emotion
to what's happening with the dancer i
think is important
next up behind the candelabra i like to
try playing it now
at 16 beats
[Music]
i thought his michael douglas's plan was
phenomenal
i mean i'm actually really curious to
know
how they did that did he if he actually
played that or
because his face was in the shot it
looked like if he wasn't playing it he
was playing something close to that
it's basically like i said it was that
that boogie woogie thing
then he did it in double time and did
the stride
on a double time it that's that's
virtuoso stuff i mean that's that's
that's the best of the best stuff right
there
i call it boogie woogie but it's the
same
just that walk that that type of
i think when players do things like that
that's part of the performance
i don't think that it actually hits the
keys any differently or makes you play
any differently
that is when everything is coming
through you you know when when the
instrument becomes an extension of you
you don't want them to just hear you
playing but you want them to see you
playing
and finally corpse bride
according to plan
i don't know that i see an advantage in
playing a duet with
i mean that that sounds more like a
nightmare to me
i mean just having somebody sitting next
to you playing
like you only have these keys you know
right here and
and they have those so i think it's cool
for a movie
uh i don't think it's ideal in real life
like dueling pianos i think is cool when
you both have your whole piano to go
back and forth with i think that's cool
because
then they can play some parts that you
can't play but they still have the range
[Music]
them being in a minor key i don't know
what key they were
[Music]
it's like that minor thing versus us a
major thing
if they were playing in major it would
have sounded happy
it would have been happy but they were
and that i think that attributed to the
sadness
all right guys that's it thank you so
much for hanging with me watching these
clips with me i had so much fun
but that's a wrap i'll see you next time
peace